notre émission spéciale continue c'est
un gros plan sur le pouvoir de Benyamin
netaniaahou que je vous propose
maintenant le Premier ministre israélien
on l'a évoqué rapidement allié à des
partis d'extrême droite et
ultraorthodoxe il a laissé le ramasse
prospérer n'a pas cru à l'éventualité de
ces attaques terroristes a-t-il
aujourd'hui la légitimité politique pour
faire l'union nationale pour mener cette
guerre avant d'en débattre r tour sur
son histoire avec Fabien RER Benjamin
netanahou en chef de guerre appelle à
l'union
nationale citoyens israéliens nous
sommes dans une guerre pour notre
foyer une guerre pour assurer notre
existence une guerre que nous
gagnerons si depuis samedi les partis
d'opposition font bloc derrière le
Premier ministre il s'agit d'une trêve
fragile pour Benyamin netanahou coupable
aux yeux d'une partie des israélien
d'avoir fait entrer l'extrême droite au
gouvernement au lendemain des
législatives de 2022 Benjamin netanahou
affaibli par un scandale de corruption
fait alliance avec le colon
ultraorthodoxe bezalels motrich et le
suprémaciste juif Itamar benengvir une
aile dure qui aggrave les relations avec
les Palestiniens en multipliant les
provocations comme lorsquitamar Benv se
rend sur l'esplanade des mosquées où les
prières de religieux juifs brisent le
consensus autour des lieux saints à
Jérusalem mais le gouvernement se
distingue surtout par un soutien débridé
à la colonisation en
Jordanie nous n'avons pas peur nous
avons légalisé neuf avantpostes et avec
l'aide de Dieu nous en légaliserons des
dizaine d'autres un feu vert à la
colonisation qui entraîne son lot
d'affrontement et d'exaction avant
l'attaque du 7 octobre l'année 2023
était déjà en passe de devenir la plus
meurtrière depuis 15 ans pour les
Palestiniens de s Jordanie selon Human
Right Watch de quoi attiser la colère
côté palestinien mais aussi désorganiser
les services de sécurité israélien cette
situation absolument tendue en S
Jordanie d'oppression des Palestiniens
et surtout d'exaction des colons a
multiplié la tentation armée côté
palestinien avec la création de nouveaux
groupes qui a contraint l'armée
israélienne à se redéployer au détriment
de la bande de Gaza et au profit de la
sis Jordanie et c'est ce qui a notamment
permis au groupe armé Palestiniens de la
bande de Gaza Hamas appuyé par le jadis
palestinien d'organiser cette opération
et de pénétrer aussi facilement sur le
territoire israélien l'attaque du 7
octobre a frappé une société
profondément divisée après 9 mois de
manifestation contre la réforme
judiciaire de Benjamin netanahou une
réforme qui redéfinit les règles du jeu
de la démocratie israélienne plus
éloigné que jamais de la paix et pour
débattre du rôle de la responsabilité de
benjamine netaniaahou j'accueille
Vincent Lemir bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes historien professeur à
l'université Gustave etit l'ancien
directeur du centre de recherche
français à Jérusalem et vous publiez
histoire de Jérusalem aux éditions Les
Arènes Armel charier bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
éditoraliste international à France 24
spécialiste en géopolitique stratégie et
défense Steve Jourdain bonsoir Steve
journaliste à public sénatons no
téléspectateurs vous connaissent mais ne
savent pas forcément que vous êtes
docteur en histoire et spécialiste
d'Israël vous avez publié Israël
autopsie d'une gauche aux éditions le
bord de l'eau bienvenue à vous et
Léticia CR éitorialiste politique est
évidemment resté à mes côtés euh benam
Benjamin netaniaou on va évidemment
consacrer ce second débat
essentiellement à à son histoire sa
responsabilité est-ce que vous dites
Vincent lumè que c'est ce qui se passe
c'est aussi ou peut-être d'abord je ne
sais pas l'échec de netanahù ah bah
c'est oui d'abord dans parce que c'est
la cause c'est c'est l'échec et c'est la
fin je là je en Israël pas seulement
dans la presse de gauche ou de centre
gauche ou de centre- droit mais je ve
dire les critiques sont d'une violence
c'est presque par qu'à la limite la
seule question c'est de savoir quand
estce qu'il part qu là il y avait
c'était arrê hier c'était pas dans 3
jours pas dans 3 mois maintenant il doit
partir titre du quotidien arrête c'est
ça voilà
euh et puis pour les autres c'est à la
minute quand la guerre sera finie il
devra partir il est il est absolument
carbonisé alors je sais qu'on dit
toujours que natanahou est un phénomène
rebondissant et cetera et et un culbuto
mais mais mais là c'est autre chose je
veux dire le c'est pas seulement encore
une fois je suis pas le premier à le
dire mais c'est pas seulement un un
échec des systèmes de de renseignement
et même des systèmes de sécurité c'est
l'échec d'une stratégie globale
euh qui a consisté à quoi entre
guillemets choisir le ramas comme son
meilleur etnemi quoi mais encore une
fois je je je suis obligé de de de
rappeler cette cette phrase terrible
qu'ad dis smotrc on record à la radio
ces derniers mois betalels motr ministre
des Finances en charge aujourd'hui de de
notamment de la du financement de la
colonisation en en sisjordanie pendant
la campagne électorale sm motrc dit
l'Autorité palestinienne est notre
fardeau le Hamas est notre chance et
nataniaahou a rappelé ça dans des
réunions de cabinet encore ces dernières
semaines en disant si vous voulez
avancer sur votre plan d'annexion d'un
côté il faut continuer d'humilier
l'Autorité palestinienne et le Hamas de
ce point de vue- là est notre allié
c'est c'est le c'est le c'est c'est la
suite d'une d'une long stratégie mais là
porté à un camp d'esence Armel char il
symbolise un pouvoir fort sécuritaire
netaniaou et donc il est forcément
fragilisé sur ce qui ce qui était censé
faire sa force c'est aussi à ça que l'on
assiste est ce que vous dites oui alors
on le surmom bibi c'était bibi la
sécurité c'est vraiment la la il était
même avec une certaine adoration par un
certain nombre de
d'Israéliens parce que il représentait
justement cette capacité à j'allais dire
à définir quel était l'ennemi
c'est-à-dire redonner en fait une un
terme aux Palestiniens dans un pays qui
a plus de gauche en fait c'est ça le
problème c'est que la gauche a
complètement disparu parce qu'elle
aurait sa place vous pouvez avoir un
discours qui soit un discours
pacificateur à côté et ce discours là on
on ne le voit plus on ne l'entend plus
donc il a eu un boulevard pour lui en
jouant sur cette phénomène de sécurité
c'est vrai CELI qui lu protège est-ce
qu'il était présenté comme ça ah il
était présenté comme étant celui qui
était capable effectivement d' un moment
donné d'avoir un discours dur vis àv des
Palestiniens d'avoir une capacité de
diriger un mur d'avoir une capacité
effectivement de de fermer les
frontières quand il le fallait ensuite
il y a eu cette bascule à partir d'un
moment donné où il y a eu toutes ces
alliances avec l'extrême droite et
cetera et où là il y a eu une politique
qui était avec les colons qui est une
politique aussi avec les les
ultraorthodoxes donc une politique avec
des gens très religieux donc là qui
était pas forcément toujours la même
chose queune po une société israélienne
qui peut être comme ça généralement plus
à Jérusalem mais quand vous êtes à
Telavi vous quoi que ce soit vous avez
bien vu la société qu'on voit dans la
rêve partie c'est aussi une société qui
ne peut ne pas croire qui peut juste
vouloir faire la fête et cetera donc
c'est vrai qu'il y avait il y avait en
fait différentes variantes j'allais dire
deam naniamou mais en revanche il a
toujours correspondu au fait que c'était
celui qui acceptait le morcellement du
territoire palestinien oui Steve J on
parlait dans notre première partie de
d'union nationale et certains témoins
disait que finalement l'Union nationale
était en était à l'œuvre mais vous avez
non non mais alors oui peut-être mais
mais à quel point les critiques
justement s'expriment et dans ce climat
voilà où où finalement il y a des des
images d'horreur qui qui tombent tous
les jours oui j'apporterai juste
peut-être une petite nuance à ce qu' a
dit Vincent évidemment il y a beaucoup
de critiques aujourd'hui contre
nthanielou il y a eu cette éditoriale du
du AR il y a beaucoup de voix qui
s'expriment qui montrent nthanou comme
principal responsable des échecs mais je
pense que ça va beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui c'est pas netan évidemment
une responsabilité on parle de la
manière qu'il a eu de disposer certains
bataillons est-ce qu'ils auraient dû
être plus au nord de Gaza plus au sud
plus à l'aise bon il y a une
responsabilité mais faut pas faut faut
se rappeler aussi qu'il y a un an
nataniahou n'était pas au pouvoir il y
avait un gouvernement qui était alors on
va pas dire de gauche mais un
gouvernement de centre-droit qui était
mené par l'opposition l'opposition qui
critique aujourd'hui netania donc qui a
aussi une responsabilité de de des voilà
benigans et notamment Yair lapide donc
vous dire qu'ils on ils ont pas mené une
politique bien différente vis-à-vis de
la V de Gaza et du ramas c'est ça c'estd
que c'est un peu facile j'ai assez écrit
contre netanahou depuis des années pour
voilà pour pas avoir voilà je prends un
peu C défense d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui mais on sait ce que je pense
plus ou moins il suffit de me lire mais
netanou n'est pas le principal
responsable ça va beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui il y a une responsabilité
des services de sécurité du
renseignement militaire une
responsabilité de l'armée et il faut
voir à quel point l'armée israélienne
est importante en Israël ce qui se passe
c'est pas simplement entre guillemets
simplement 1000 morts c'est une crise de
confiance comme on n' pas vécu depuis la
guerre du Kipour on parle beaucoup de la
guerre du Kipour il y aura une enquête
sans doute qui inculpera certaines
personnalités politiques et cetera mais
il faut mesurer à quel point aujourd'hui
la société israélienne euh
est va possiblement se retourner contre
des responsables militaires contre des
responsables politiques et nthanou sera
pas le seul à à être visé et juste juste
pour
terminer Israël s'est construit sur euh
son armée sur tsal sur ce qu'on a appelé
la Hagana avant 1948 c'est une armée qui
s'est construite sur l'autodéfense pour
défendre les Juifs qui avaient besoin
d'un état après la choix et même en 1920
quand l'armée serée donc c'est une armée
qui qui se légitime à ses propres yeux
au regard de la violence qu'elle subit
et aujourd'hui pour la première fois
peut-être depuis 1967 donc la guerre de
6 jours l'armée et les Israéliens
regardent cette armée comme protectrice
et d'une certaine man manère va lui
laisser les mains libres pour faire ce
qu'elle a à faire à Gaza et c'est la
première fois depuis peut-être les
années 80 où Israël redevient en
position de défense oui alors c'est
intéressant parce que au contraire dans
l'argumentaire de du du Hamas on entend
que la toute puuissance de l'armée
israélienne a été mise à bas je vous
propose d'écouter le secrétaire général
de l'Initiative nationale palestinienne
pour être
précis
palestin la résistance palestinienne
malgré ses ressources limitées a réussi
à briser l'image de la toutepuissance de
israélienne Israël a échoué sur le plan
militaire sur le plan de la sécurité et
sur le plan
stratégique la résistance palestinienne
a réussi à remettre la question
palestinienne sur la table et à faire
échouer ce que netaniahou avait tenté de
faire à savoir marginaliser et liquider
le dossier palestinien par le BIA d'une
normalisation avec les pays
arabes alors on y reviendra sur cette
partie diplomatique mais Vincent lemier
sur au sein du gouvernement netaniaahou
il y a il y a des militaires de carrière
il y a des gens qui ont cette expérience
ou pas non mais c'est bien le là
d'ailleurs les discussion pour savoir
s'il peut y avoir un gouvernement
d'union nationale c'est c'est d'abord
les clown sortent quoi pardon mais c'est
les c'est les discours qui sont employés
Benv smotr déjà dehors
quoion puisse travailler qu'on puisse
travailler c'est entre professionnel
entre gens qui savent faire
quoi mais mais Natan lui-même savait que
c'est de
il il lui apportait des députés benvir
c'est c'est six députés et natthaniao il
a quatre députés de majorité donc il ne
servait qu'à ça je veux dire euh et à et
a essayé de de ramener un vote d'extrême
droite mais je veux dire c'est pas des
ministres au sens opérationnel du du
terme voilà il leors se l'agenda c'est
la colonisation et l'annexion de la de
la sjordanie donc c'est pas un agenda de
sécurité et d'ailleurs eux-mêmes ne le
ne le ne le prétendent pas on est quand
même on est dans il y a là c'est pas moi
qui le dit mais c'est pareil il y a
toute une critique en ce moment en
Israël qui dit que que ces ministres là
sont des ministres postionistes voire
antisionistes mais quel point on ses
ministres sont deux est-ce que problème
c'est que Benv il a 6 députés la
majorité c'est c'est quatre donc en une
heure Benv fait sauter voilà mais à la
limite on est presque plus sur sur ces
questionnement là je veux dire c de là
vont s'ans doute sortir et il va y avoir
on va être dans autre chose mais je
voudrais juste c'est
pour ce qu'a dit Steve Jourdain sur la
sur la question de oui de l'armée et
cetera mais encore plus profondément sur
le plan historique rappeler que l'enjeu
de sécurité est fondateur dans
l'histoire d'Israël c'est un état qui a
été créé pour mettre en sécurité les
juifs menacés par l'antisémitisme dans
le monde entier donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est pas un élément
accessoire du consensus national quand
il y a un attentat ailleurs bon c'est
terrible c'est ça remet en cause le le
sens même et la justification de l'État
lui-même et du projet ou donc ça touche
oui ça touche mais c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on a des on a des amis
israéliens est-ce que je reste est-ce
que je pars et cetera parce que c'est
même pas c'est en fait on est là d'abord
et avant tout pour être en sécurité
normalement à part ceux qui on en agenda
messianique théocratique et cetera mais
on va dire les sionistes on va dire
standard normaux sont aussi en Israël
pour vivre un judaïsme en sécurité avoir
une kipa sans enfin ça c'est le discours
normal c'est le concep normale donc
quand la sécurité est attaquée c'est le
projet national lui-même qui est touché
mais d'ailleurs Armel char ça ça
explique parce que quand on n'est pas
connaisseur de la société israélienne on
se dit mais comment on peut organiser
une rêvepartie à à quelques kilomètres
de la de la bande de Gaza il y a ce
sentiment de sécurité qui était partagé
par par tout le pays donc ça c'est une
faille profonde qui s'est ouverte
d'après vous oui il y a certainement euh
en fait c'est compliqué Israël parce que
déjà euh c'est tout petit et en fait
c'est cet espace qui est vraiment si
condensé qui change considérablement la
donne et et vous avez raison parce que
quand on fait une rve partie à 6 km de
Gaza il y a à la fois la notion de
liberté absolue la notion qu'on est dans
son pays en même temps quand on regarde
de l'extérieur quand on se rappelle que
Gaza c'est 2 millions de personnes qui
sont complètement dans un enclos il y a
aussi quelque chose d'assez d'assez fou
de se dire qu'on est capable de faire du
bruit alors que les autres ne sont même
pas capables de pouvoir aller nager dans
l'eau s'ils ont envie d'y aller et c'est
ça en fait Israël en permanence et donc
c'est vrai que cette jeunesse elle a
aussi ce besoin à un moment donné de vie
elle a besoin d'avoir une une économie
elle a besoin d'avoir de l'argent elle a
besoin de pouvoir faire la fête il y a
tout ça aussi qui se met en place et
c'est vrai aussi que c'est peut-être ces
failles finalement qu'on voit dans la
société israélienne qui ont été observé
par des pays arabes par les pays
extérieurs et cetera qui font que vous
aviez une construction israëlienne qui
était une construction de gens qui
défendaient Israël qui étit dans les
kibuts qui avait justement aussi cette
notion de s'il faut se battre on y va et
puis aujourd'hui vous avez cette société
qui arrive parce que elle considère que
elle peut profiter de la vie et que
Israël est acquise que Israël le pays
est acquis et donc du coup l'envie c'est
d'envie de faire de l'argent c'est
l'envie d'aller voyager c'est l'envie de
s'amuser et surtout c'est aussi je
terminerai juste parce que c'est une
photographie mais c'est un pays qui
connaît en permanence les attentat donc
on Nimagine pas à quel point c'est une
société qui est résiliante c'est-à-dire
que la jeunesse elle quand elle peut
faire la fête elle fait la fête si vous
avez un attentat et que du coup vous
êtes en terrasse et ben vous vous faites
la fête en étant à l'intérieur mais vous
continuez quand même à vivre parce que
c'est aussi un pays qui a la choix et
donc qui quoi qu'il arrive se dit qu'il
faut continuer à à à progresser dans la
vie si on parlait de de de l'imaginaire
en tout cas de de de de toute
l'arrière-plan israélien qui est qui est
touché l'armée effectivement la sécurité
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous disiez
Vincent on n pas beaucoup parlé des
kibuts parce que c'est des kibuts donc
les ces villages frontaliers de la band
de Gaza qui ont été principalement
touchés dans l'imaginaire israélien
c'est très important le kibut c'est la
première pierre vers l'état d'Israël
c'est les premières implantations en
Palestine c'est quelque chose qui qui
parle encore aujourd'hui aux Israéliens
qui s'est transmis de génération en
génération et voilà on faut le rappeler
encore il y a pas de de de mort de
gauche de mort de droite mais les gens
qui étaient dans ces kibou c'étaient des
gens qui sur plusieurs générations
avaient un rêve un rêve de solidarité un
rêve d'entraide et qui on se sont
rrouvés en première ligne ce sont pas ce
que vous nous dites ce sont pas
forcément les électeurs de bamin non non
je veux pas rentrer dans dans Ça c'est
voilà il y a une boucherie un massacre
c'est c'est c'est pas parce on a on a
entendu sur ce plateau même hier des des
analyses ou des accusations disant que
Benjamin natianou finalement avait en en
déplaçant un certain nombre de de de de
de militaire privilégier plutôt la
protection de son électorat et en
ciblant les colons en protégeant les
colons ça c'est une interprétation à
laquelle je je je me range pas forcément
mais juste voilà je voulais insister sur
cette imageord imaginaire israélien qui
est brisé aujourd'hui qui a reçu un coup
très fort c'est que voilà les kibuts
c'est la première pierre vers l'état
d'Israël l'armée c'est la deuxième
pierre en tout cas c'est une des
premières pierres à faire l'état
d'Israël et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
Israël se sent attaqué en état de siège
et ça peut expliquer aussi les réactions
qu'on va voir dans les jours qui
viennent alors on débat à ce moment de
l'émission autour de Benjamin netaniaou
et de sa capacité finalement à mener le
pays dans ce contexte notamment on a
commencé à l'évoquer à à fédérer autour
de lui une forme union nationale on va
en parler tout de suite avec Quentin
Calmet rebonsoir Quentin rebonsoir
Thomas donc benjamine natthanou qui
cherche à former ce gouvernement d'union
nationale dites-nous tout oui c'est en
cours de négociation ça pourrait même
voilà être scellé dans les minutes qui
viennent il y a trois partis politiques
qui négocie d'abord le licou de Benyamin
netaniaou avec deux autres parties du
centre ou du centre droit d'ailleurs
d'un côté commençons avec le Parti de
l'unité nationale de Benny gansz ce
parti est dans l'opposition actuellement
à netaniaou il compte 12 membres sur les
120 que compte la cessette et il apporté
une revendication qu'un cabinet de
guerre soit mis en place avec une
représentation de son parti et une
réelle influence pour ses membres sur la
gestion de la guerre afin de rejoindre
le gouvernement c'est cette condition
hein qui est et bien qui est en cours de
négociation benigans c'est important
vous l'avez dit en plateau c'est un
ancien chef de l'état-major de l'armée
il est donc l'un des hommes politiques
de premier plan avec une expérience
militaire autre figure au centre des
négociations hier lapide oui le leader
du parti centriste Laï yatide qui
représente lui 24 députés sur les 120 il
fait également partie des négociations y
lapide a été l'un des premiers
d'ailleurs à parler de gouvernement
d'urgence ce parti cherche à se
débarrasser d'ailleurs des ministres
d'extrême droite qui sont membres depuis
novembre 2022 de la coalition autour de
netaniaou on voit deux ministres
particulièrement visés il pourrai donc
et bien faire l'objet de ces
négociations faire les frais de ces
négociations pour que le gouvernement se
recentre on parle pas par exemple de
l'actuelle ministre de la Sécurité
Intérieure Itamar ben gvir connu pour
ses positions racistes ultra radicales
contre les Arabes et c'est plus
compliqué pour un deuxè ministre un
deuxè leader de l'extrême droite le
parti suniste religieux bzalel SMC lui
et ben Benjamin netaniaou et bien
insiste pour qu'il continue à être au
gouvernement il a fixé netaniaah cinq
priorités pour son gouvernement d'unité
c'était dans son allocution hier voilà
notamment l'unité du peuple avec la form
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale
c'est l'un des cinq points effectivement
qui a été évoqué hier lors de la
loocution également récupérer le
contrôle du territoire et je cite
éliminer les terroristes encore présents
en Israël 3ème axe mener une attaque
massive contre le Hamas avec une force
inédite je cite encore renforcer les
autres fonds notamment au nord face au
hzbollah et en sjordanie enfin continuer
la campagne pour garantir le soutien de
la communauté internationale la
coalition en tout cas qui est en train
de se faire entre les trois parties
qu'on évoquait ne pourrait durer que le
temps de la guerre contre le Hamas car
car le parti par exemple de benigans a
déjà annoncé que il retournerait dans
l'opposition dès que la guerre prendra
fin Thomas merci beaucoup Quentin armet
charier on a beaucoup parlé dans la
première partie de l'émission de la
question des des otages est-ce que avant
une une éventuelle opération militaire
terrestre dans la bande de Gaza est-ce
que la la création ou l'accord autour
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale est
un préalable à cette opération militaire
d'après vous est-ce que Benjamin Nanou a
besoin de cette union nationale pour
pour finalement frapper aussi fort qu'il
le souhaite il en a certainement besoin
oui parce que ça va lui donner de la
crédibilité après on est quand même je
pense dans un pays qui est largement
deuillé en ce moment donc la notion
politique elle est la l'Union nationale
elle a quand même lieu maintenant parce
qu'il faut défendre ce qui a été attaqué
parce que il y a cette question des
otages qui et on imagine meurtri
complètement des familles en ce moment
on n pas que celles qui sont deillé euh
130 otage peut-être est-ce qu'on
arrivera à les sortir tous une vraie
question est-ce qu'on en sortira qu'une
simple partie ce qu'on aurait jamais vu
de la part des Israéliens parce qu'à un
moment donné ils peuvent négocier et en
se disant qu'à partir du moment donné où
ils ont eu 1000 morts ce qui est une
première pour eux pour un pays qui est 6
millions de se dire que et bien ils
n'iront peut-être pas jusqu'au bout donc
c'est vrai que Benyamin netaniao s'il a
un gouvernement plus élargi plus
stabilisé avec des personnes plus
différentes qui viennent à l'épauler
forcément ça lui donne une crédibilité
de plus mais dans ces premiers jours je
pense quand même que la situation
quelque part légitime de toute manière
tout toute poussée qu'il puisse y avoir
je je vous pose la même question Vincent
lemè est-ce que Benjamin nou a a besoin
de ce gouvernement d'union nationale
pour mener l'opération militaire qui
l'annonce bah dans dans l'état où il est
oui forcément mais c'est encore une fois
c'est pas c'est le pays qui en a besoin
dire quand le vu la vu la force du choc
qui s'est passé l' des images et la
violence de ce qui va
arriver bah ça s'appelle un gouvernement
de guerre en fait voilà mais encore une
fois c'est pas et d'ailleurs benigand
dit exactement ça il dit à la fin des
combats donc et donc natthaniaou saute
il y a pas c'est mathématique il va pas
les récupérer ensuite Benv ou si ou ça
c'est assez intéressant que la
négociation se fasse sur bengvir smotrc
c'est plutôt logique he on va dire le
plus le plus voyant le plus Tony Truant
c'est bengvir on va dire le plus clown
des deux c'est très largement benengvir
le plus sérieux et le plus dangereux
c'est largement smotrich est-ce que ça
provoquer plus de soutien de la part de
la communauté internationale est-ce que
ça donne aussi un peu une oui ça fera un
gouvernement oui ça fera un gouvernement
un peu plus oui un peu plus acceptable
forcément benigand c'est quelqu'un de
enfin voilà c'est pas c'est on change
mais mais motric j'y insiste ce motric
est beaucoup plus dangereux que Benv
c'est motric a un vrai agenda d'extrême
droite puis c'est quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus froid
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins expansif
beaucoup moins provocateur mais qu' un
vrai agenda qui a une vraie ligne et il
sait très bien ce qu'il veut faire et
qui pèse quel c'est quel poids dans le
aux élections dans l'opinion dans c'est
quoi c'est 12 à de ils font 12 13 ils
font 13 à de ils font 13 alors c'est
juste 13 députés sur alors 13 députés
sur 120 ça fait un peu plus de 10 %
d'accord mais par exemple c'est juste
pour vous donner les travaillistes qui
ont construit cet état qu aujourd'hui
c'est quatre députés d'accord et quand s
descend encore un tout PE il y aura plus
de députés donc dans le dans l'état
actuel du du du du champ politique
électoral israélien 13 c'est beaucoup
hein voilà si jourin est-ce que vous
pourrez je vois vous vouz intervenir
mais je vais quand même vous poser une
question est-ce que Benjamin c'est un
VAT en guerre est-ce que dans son
Histoire politique il a souvent mené la
guerre c'est un craintif c'est pas c'est
un des des premier ministres qui est le
moins VAT en guerre de l'histoire
d'Israël mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'il y aura un avant et un après quoi
qu'il arrive voilà on parle aujourd'hui
de négociation de tractation politique
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un gouver
ouement d'union d'unité nationale ou pas
Benjamin Tanou a utilisé une formule
très intéressante lors de sa prise de
parole il a dit que qu' qu'il allait
changer qu'il fallait changer le
Moyen-Orient alors il y a une référence
historique derrière voilà alors tout le
monde l'a pas même en Israël il ont pas
forcément noté mais le dernier avoir
employé cette formule cétait Ariel
Charon au moment de l'invasion et de la
guerre du Liban il voulait redissiner
les cartes du Moyen-Orient Benjamin
etanou quand il parle de ça il a
forcément ça en tête c'est un homme
d'histoire son père est un grand
historien de de l'histoire de l'histoire
juive c'est un homme de culture il sait
très bien quand il emplo ses mots ce
qu'il veut dire et ce qu'il veut faire
il a sans doute une idée à la tête c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas invent en guerre
c'est quelqu'un qui n'aime pas la guerre
parce qu'il sait que il y a un prix
politique très fort à à payer après une
guerre après des conflits mais
certainement qu'il a une idée à la tête
et quand il emploie cette formule il
sait où il va
d'acc je ne sais pas lu le sait non mais
vous dites quoi c'est il est il est il
faut
ire c'est-à-dire qu'il laess il est
obsédé en fait par l'image qu'il va
laisser dans l'histoire benamit c'est
pas à nouveau ça fait plusieurs années
qui qui il essaie de travailler sa
sortie entre guillemets c'est il a plus
il a plus 30 ans il a plus 40 ans il
s'accroche au pouvoir mais il essaie de
de travailler sa sortie et ce qu'il va
laisser dans l'histoire aujourd'hui il a
un moment charnière dans sa vie
politique il est poursuivi en justice il
y a cette guerre qui éclate qui est une
guerre qui il y a pas d'équivalent dans
l'oire Israël en tout cas un fiasco qui
n'a pas d'équivalent dans l'histoire
d'Israël il est un moment crucial et il
va devoir prendre la décision et il
utilise cette formule c'est intéressant
de voir ce qu'il va en faire maintenant
alors moi je posais la question mais du
coup je vais je vais essayer de de
donner ben non parce qu'on sait très
bien il a que trois mauvaises options on
dit toujours bombardement massif il tue
les otages et puis ça va en plus ça va
gêner encore plus les opérations
terrestres opération terrestre elle va
arriver mais parce qu'on met pas 300000
réservistes comme ça pour rien mais ça
va être extrêmement extrêmement
meurtrier et compris pour l'armée
israélienne et puis voilà euh
négociation c'est en fait peut-être ou
négociation partielle mais ça aura un
cooup politique
énorme la dernière option c'est que et
là c'est une discussion c'est pas
seulement nataniahou ni le gouvernement
israélien c'est une discussion avec les
États-Unis il faut bien aussi entendre
ce que blinken dit en ce moment là c'est
la fenêtre de tir éventuelle sur l'Iran
euh c'est que là c'est c'est c'est
l'obsession de nataniaoou l'Iran depuis
15 ans ça veut dire quoi fenêre de tir
sur l'Iran bah ça veut dire taper ça
veut dire
l'Irak a été tapé sur une sur une vous
vous souvenez sur une petite éprouvette
qui contenait euh rien du tout pas
d'armes de destruction massive il y aura
on aura pas de mal à prouver les liens
entre l'Iran et le Hamas ça veut pas
forcément dire des liens opérationnels
je suis pas du tout en train de dire que
c'est l'Iran qui a organisé tout ça on
trouvera on trouvera largement ce qu'il
faut je dis juste donc ça c'est le
risque de l'escalade on dire mais je je
je je je dialogue avec avec Steve
Jourdain je je est c'est conforme à ce
que vous connaissez netanahou ça bah
alors non parce que il a jamais été inv
VAT en guerre oui parce qu'il est dans
un plus que dans un corner il est dans
une impasse totale et qu'il y a que des
mauvaises solutions et oui parce que il
a fait de l'Iran ce serait cohérent on
va dire avec son parcours et avec son
discours depuis le début et et et donc
mais mais ça ne pourrait se faire que
avec l'aval et et même la décision des
États-Unis hein là évidemment arm
charier votre avis là-dessus bah déjà
pour faire avec l'aval des États-Unis le
problème c'est que si on se lance sur
une guerre à longue à longue haline
comme ça il faut aussi beaucoup
d'armement en ce moment on a une guerre
en Ukraine qui en a dispendu du coup il
y en a beaucoup qui ont été donné là on
sait que les Israéliens ont déjà demandé
de l'armement pour renfouer le dô de fer
parce que si on met tout en route grosso
modo les Israéliens tient forcément une
guerre oui oui mais 10 jours et s'il y a
des frappes qui sont extrêmement ouais
après ça fait partie de l'obsession
j'allais dire israélienne et de net sur
question identifi ouais alors après
peut-être peut-être parce pour essayer
de donner quand même une une logique
plus positive mais mais je pense que
l'Iran c'est pas forcément la solution
vers laquelle les Américains ont envie
d'aller en tout cas les Israéliens
peut-être Benyamine Ettien les
Américains je pense pas que ce soit le
moment o ne suffise pas à
décider frappe surir on est d'accord
après il faut voilà on est aussi dans un
monde où en ce moment il y a on on est
en train de se revoir avec avec le
fonctionnement avec la Chine avec les
bricks avec Taiwan on a toute tout ça
qui se met en place alors oui évidemment
les guerres c'est une étincelle et donc
on ne maîtrise pas il y a pas la raison
Rais qui fait que à un moment donné donc
évidemment que ça peut traverser
l'esprit mais raisonnablement en ce
moment ce serait quand même compliqué
alors justement on va parler de de un
peu de de diplomatie des alliés
internationaux de de benjamine
netaniaahou laticia et et des mots qui
choisisse on va commencer évidemment
avec un focus sur la France les mots
choisis par Emmanuel Macron oui Emmanuel
Macron est pris en tenaille entre
finalement l'équilibre géopolitique
qu'il faut absolument respecter mais
aussi l'opinion publique Fran fr Thomas
on le sait elle a tendance à être
divisée sur cette question du du conflit
israélopalestinien qu'on importe sans
cesse sur notre sol donc Emmanuel Macron
a décidé d'avancer avec prudence mais ça
n'empêche pas que dès les premières
heures la position de la France a été
très claire par un tweet qui a écrit
Emmanuel Macron il a dit samedi je
condamne fermement les attaques
terroristes qui frappent actuellement
Israël j'exprime ma pleine solidarité
avec les victimes leur famille et leurs
proches et il n'a pas bougé de cette
position il a seulement ajouté ensuite
dans le sillon de Joe Biden et d'Ursula
V leyon qu'Israël avait le droit de se
défendre ouis ça c'est vraiment la
position aussi de l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne qui reste quand même
assez mesurée dans sa condamnation on
peut dire ça oui notamment on en parlait
là sur ce plateau au sujet de l'Iran
alors il y a eu un petit quak on ne sait
pas si c'est un quak ou si c'est un
rétrédalage mais en tout cas cette nuit
Emmanuel Macron a écrit un tweet un peu
avant minuit oui qui parlait donc il est
juste pour contextualisé il est en
Allemagne pour un séminaire
gouvernemental franco-allemand et il
faisait part d'une déclaration commune
entre l'Allemagne la France l'Italie le
Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis où les
Alliés appelaient les autres pays en
particulier l'Iran il était marqué en
particulier l'Iran à ne exploiter cette
situation à d'autres fins pourquoi vous
parlez de retop pédalage le site
d'information politico a remarqué que ce
tweet quelques minutes après a disparu
pour être remplacé par un autre tweet où
la mention à l'Iran a disparu on peut le
voir on a retrouvé le tweet voilà et on
voit que le passage où il y a plus le le
le le pays n'est pas cité l'Iran n'est
pas cité en particulier l'Iran ça ça a
disparu ça a disparu il a dû répondre
là-dessus le président français
aujourd'hui oui par par qu'il était en
conférence de presse à Hambourg donc
avec Olaf Scholz et un journaliste
s'estlevé lui a posé la question de
pourquoi cette pension à l'Iran a
disparu écoutez la réponse du président
j'ai pas de commentaire à faire sur
l'implication directe de l'Iran dont
nous n'avons pas la trace de manière
formelle mais il est clair qu'à la fois
les propos publics tenus par les
autorités iraniennes sont inacceptables
et ne correspondent pas ni à nos valeurs
ni à nos intérêts et qu'ensuite il est
vraisemblable qu'il y ait eu des aides
apportées au Hamas et des coopérations
mais je resterai prudent sur ce point
tant que nous n'avons pas stabilisé des
élément de renseignement totalement sûr
voilà le président français qui est
également prudent c'est le maître mot de
votre chronique en direction de la
l'opinion publique française oui parce
qu'il y a déjà un début de polémique à
propos de ce siège à Gaza et puis des
souffrances he bien sûr qui sont subis
par les palanestinens on le sait depuis
40 ans le conflit Israël palestinien est
instrumentalisé sur notre sol Thomas
donc Emmanuel Macron a choisi de
désamorpher à à cette même conférence de
presse là justement avec Olaf Scholz il
a insisté encore lourdement il a
condamné fermement le terrorisme mais il
a ajouté aussi qu'il fallait absolument
respecter le droit humanitaire
international sous-entendant qu'il
n'était pas favorable à un blocus total
de Gaza et par exemple vous savez l'OM a
demandé un corridor humanitaire on sent
que la France est aussi sur cette
position là il a vu que la franceoumise
avait récupéré très vite et avait
récupéré cette question en dénonçant les
Israéliens qui allaient faire subir au
Gazaoui les pire souffrance et donc
c'est l'Élysée hein qui fait savoir à la
presse en tout cas quand on leur pose la
question qu'effectivement c'est la
prudence queemmanuel Macron a choisi
pourquoi pour que personne ne puisse
instrumentaliser ses prises de parole
merci laticia je voudrais qu'on reste
sur ce rétropédalage je vais reprendre
le terme que vous employez sur l'Iran
Armel charier c'est évidemment bon voilà
maintenant tout le monde l'a vu tout le
monde le sait comment vous l'interprétez
ça je pense que déjà à l'heure actuelle
la France a une situation
particulièrement compliquée avec l'Iran
avec le gouvernement iranien en ce
moment d'abord parce qu'il y a des
prisonniers hein il y a des otages qui
sont des on parti des bationaux d'autres
qui ne le sont pas donc et que là il y a
des tractations qui vont qu'ensuite sur
le dossier du nucléaire la France et les
pays européens font partie de ceux qui
ne croient plus du tout en l'Iran et que
de façon très pragmatique quand on vient
vraiment à discuter on se rend compte
que les Américains sont beaucoup plus en
fait en négociation sont beaucoup plus
déjà dans la façon de parler on a vu à
un moment donné quand ils ont accepté de
de libérer une partie de l'argent qui
était retenu en Corée et qu'ils l'ont
reversé au au aux Iraniens qu'ils ont
fait un échange et cetera donc c'est
certainement ce qui explique pourquoi
est-ce que le président PE un moment
donné aller rapidement sur la question
iranienne qui est centrale évidemment et
ensuite se dire que c'est pas forcément
le moment et que donc du coup on peut
revenir en arrière parce qu'on est sur
une négociation parce que si on fait
perdre directement la face à un pays
encore faut-il avoir des preuves
derrière et puis parce qu'à partir du
moment donné où on a enchaîné des mots
bah il faut avoir des actes derrière et
que donc dans ces cas-là si vous pouvez
déterminer ça arrangera personne he si
on arrive à déterminer clairement quels
sont les donneurs d'ordre et par où
l'argent est passé donc en fait il faut
mettre ça pas après pas HM euh sur
toujours sur vous voulez prendre la
parole non non parce que en fait B on
continue la la conversation de
précédente parce que ça c'est pour ça
çafin je veux dire encore on entend bien
que ça tout ça dépasse très largement la
question de de l'avenir politique de
natanah on est quand même en train de
parler en fait effectivement de de de de
bouleversement géopolitique
potentiellement majeur donc moi je suis
pas du tout en train de de dire que la
probabilité de de frappe sur l'Iran est
justement le plus prob vous disz c'est
l'une des hypè je dis que je dis si
j'étais à la place de nataniiaou je je
je penserais que c'est une option mais
je pense que en fait ça n'est pas
possible parce que c'est une décision
américaine c'est pas une décision
israélienne donc et et je suis
entièrement d'accord pour dire queà
priori c'est pas l'agenda de ni de
blinkol ni de Biden et cetera et que au
contraire ça j'aiai déjà dit et en fait
un événement de cette ampleur là un tel
choc je rappelle juste là c'est
l'historien mais c'est après la guerre
de Kipour on a on a les accords de
candevide entre entre l'Égypte et Israël
et y compris entre Sadat et qui avait
pourant déclencher cette guerre ce que
je veux dire là c'est que un un tel choc
ouvre ouvre plein de fenêtres
d'opportunités possibl et que et que qu'
il est possible aussi que les que les
États-Unis tentent quelque
chose du du bon côté quoi voilà mais je
je ouais remettre la question
palestinienne au cœur de l'agenda
politique c'est vrai Steve Jourdain que
dans la stratégie netaniiaahou c'était
tout faire dans dans même dans sa
stratégie internationale dans les Alliés
on va on va terminer en parlant de
l'Arabie Saoudite c'était de faire en
sorte que on parle plus de la question
palestinienne non c'était
effectivement son grand objectif c'était
actuellement la normalisation avec
l'Arabie Saoudite dans le cadre des
accord d'Abraham de de 2020 donc
effectivement netanahou se targue depuis
plusieurs années depuis plusieurs mois
de pouvoir évacuer contourner la
question palestinenne en faisant la paix
avec les pays arabes c'était un c'est un
de ces ses créd c'est de dire vous voyez
moi je peux faire la paix avec les pays
arabes chose que personne n'est arrivé à
faire avant lui je peux faire la paix
avec les pays arabes sans mettre la
question palestinenne au centre du jeu
pour ça ce qu'il a fait c'est de dire
diviser les Palestiniens en deux d'un
côté la S Jordanie de l'autre Gaza et
voilà de de maquiller cette question
palestinienne sous des accords les
accords d'Abraham la normalisation qui
devait arriver avec l'Arabie Saoudite et
qui peut-être enfin n'est pas
complètement enterré mais faudra voir
les réactions de la rue arabe va falloir
voir les réactions des des des pays
arabes dans les mois qui viennent
surtout si une guerre d'ampleur se
prépare le premier communiqué saoudien
est quand même très très clair et il est
pesé il vient du ministre des Affaires
étrangères re et il est arrivé à il est
arrivé vers 15h 16h samedi il est long
il y a pas un mot de
condamnation l'attaque du Hamas et toute
la responsabilité est portée sur Israël
avec des points spécifiques avec les
provocations sur les lieux saints
musulmans avec la colonisation et cetera
période alors que donc a priori ça
semble bien bien mal parti sauf option
deuxème option dont je parlais on
renverse entièrement la table ce que
demande l'Autorité palestinienne pour
avaliser on va dire l'accord avec les
saudiens c'est des cacahuètes hein
franchement
au jour d'aujourd'hui dans le dans le
grand bazar dans lequel on est donc ça
pourrait être aussi une option alors
vous vous vous nous dites effectivement
communiqué communiqué pardon de l'Arabie
Saoudite assez limpide pourtant quelques
jours auparavant puisque là je vais vous
donner un témoignage qui date du 4
octobre donc c'était il y a moins d'une
semaine on a un ministre israélien des
communications qui est en visite où en
Arabie saoudite à Riad on est en pleine
normalisation ce processus dont vous
nous parliez on
l'écoute
nous apprécions fortement les efforts
inlassables des dirigeants saoudiens et
de notre Premier ministre Benjamin
netaniaahou pour cultiver les liens
florissants entre nos nations Armel
charier on l'a bien compris on voit mal
l'Arabie saoudite à à court ou même
moyen terme réenclencher un processus
comme comme
celui-là ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que tous les efforts qui ont été fait
sont sont perdu ou qu'il y a quand même
des des liens qui se sont tissés et des
canaux de discussion qui persistent qui
sont toujours là il y a des liens qui se
sont tissés euh il y a pardon c'est moi
qui fait du Pr il y a aussi des canaux
de discussion et surtout il y a la
capacité à un moment donné d'avoir rêvé
un monde différent c'est vrai que il y
avait cette idée du Moyen-Orient
prospère que voulait MBS le prince
saoudien et donc qui était de se dire il
faut qu'on ouvre à l'économie et comme
ça on arrivera on aura pas forcément une
solution politique pour les Palestiniens
mais on aura des accords financiers ils
auront une vie meilleure et donc qu'on
pourrait aller vers là euh et c'est vrai
que du coup la décision là qui a été de
l'attaque c'est pour ça que la question
iranienne elle est flamboyante au milieu
parce que c'est vraiment est-ce que qui
qui en fait piège qui au-delà de la
question du Hamas vis-à-vis d'Israël
c'est aussi derrière qui est-ce qui
remet à dos des questions y compris avec
les pays sunites qui avaient envie de
signer là où je suis d'accord sur la
l'interprétation du du du ministre
saoudien c'est que on n'est pas avec des
pouvoirs qui sont uniques dans ces pays
al vous avez des sociétés qui ont des
envies vous avez des gouvernement qui
ont les envies vous avez un roi qui peut
avoir un envie vous avez des tonnes de
princes qui peuvent avoir chacun leur
opinion donc en fait il y a aussi à un
moment donné on prend la notion du
moment et la notion du moment c'est que
indiscutablement la question
palestinienne elle a été remise sur la
table et surtout avec l'Arabie Saoudite
qui est quand même la garante des lieux
saints donc qui va de la MEC à Médine et
qui passe aussi par la mosquée àaxa qui
est à Jérusalem donc ça veut dire
beaucoup si l'Arabie saoudit se saisit
de tout ça et c'est vrai que tout ça est
est rechamboulé parce qu'on est remis et
qu'on voit qu'il y a une cassure parce
parce que vous avez tout un ensemble de
pays qui sont des pays arabes qui sont
des pays musulmans qui eux aujourd'hui
disent mais finalement la question
palestinienne il faut qu'on em Braye il
faut qu'on la suive et cetera vous avez
toutes des anciens pays qui se disaient
de toute manière les Palestiniens ils
sont corrompus on leur a donné un
maximum d'aide pendant des années des
années des années ils en ont rien fait
donc c'est pour ça qu'on les lâche et
c'est pour ça qu'on est en train de
choisir les accords d'Abraham et
derrière vous avez cette question là
aujourd'hui saisissante de comment
est-ce qu'on se positionne merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler le le titre
de vos livres B sent leemire histoire de
Jérusalem c'est aux édition les arènes
Steve Jourdain Israël autopsie d'une
gauche au bord édition au bord de l'eau
merci encore d'avoir participé à à cette
émission je vous dis à bientôt sur
Public Sénat notez que demain sur notre
antenne l'invité de la matinale Dorian
mansini ce sera Gill Siméoni le
président du conseil exécutif de Corse
belle
[Musique]
soirée